ومن بعد مشاركته في دفعه بيروت السنه
الماضيه بدور خلدون بيطل علينا النجم
السعودي الصاعد ناصر الدوسري في رمضان
بدور مقداد في مسلسل دفعه لندن الشاب اللي
بيواجه مشكله بسبب صديق وسلطان وبيتعرض
للخيانه من عشطار
السعودي الكويت العراقي
[موسيقى]
ناصر مثل ما قلنا مشاهدينا النجم صاعد
والمنصات لمسه التطور في اداء وتمثيله سنه
عن سنه وعمل عن عمل
وينضم الينا من الكويت ناصر الدوسري اهلا
فيك معنا يا ناصر ومبروك الجدل والنجاح
والكل بيتكلم عن المسلسل
الله يبارك فيك ساره وكل عام وانت بخير
ومبارك عليكم
يا رب
المشاهدين وخواتنا وان شاء الله يعودونك
كل سنه بصحه وعافيه يا رب امين ان شاء
الله ناصر انت يعني منتقل من دفعه لدفعه
من دفعه بيروت انتقل لدفعه لندن وكيف وصلت
لدفعه لندن
خذينا البكالوريوس وكملنا بالدكتوراه ايه
واضح انه هبه مشاري وحماده يعني عاجبها
انها تحطك ضمن الدفعات يعني طبعا ايش اللي
صار كيف قالوا لك انت تعال شارك معانا في
دفعه لندن وايش قالوا لك عن الدور
والله للامانه اول شيء حابب اشكر للكاتبه
بشري حماده على اختياري في في دفعه لندن
خصوصا في شخصيه مقداد
كلموني وانا كنت اصور في لندن عمل
قالولي نحتاجك في هذا الدور فلما قريت
الدور يعني متعب جدا كاتبه يعني كاتبه اول
مره يدور مكتوب في تفاصيل عميقه
وحالات نفسيه عميقه
فاشكرها في اختيارها للدور مقداد هو يعني
اللي بيتابعوا المسلسل هم عارفين انه
مقداد مسحوق جدا يعني بشكل مو طبيعي ويمكن
انا وانت تناقشنا في الموضوع هذا وقلت لك
قديش انه انا مستفزني مقداد هل مقداد حيث
ثور لكرامته طيب شويه
والله هو ما ابي احرق بس هو راح يبين
بشخصيات او يمكن مبين بشخصيه اليوم اللي
هي حلقتناش بين شويه مقداد
[موسيقى]
بالكلام اللي يقولوله لاصحابه لما راح
يوصلها البيت عشتار ما خلاها فز قلبه شوي
بس ما قلبه عند اي احد عشان لا يمسكون من
مكان اللي عوره
قدام راح تشوفون يعني راح يصير بجار عالي
ممتاز ان شاء الله لانه يعني انا كل ما
بتفرج كل ما بكون مستفزه جدا والناس ترى
على فكره اونلاين كلهم جالسين يتكلموا على
هذا الموضوع وحتى شفناه في التغريدات يعني
انه ننتفض مقداد طب الناس اصلا من البدايه
ورجعوا كمان لكنه عاملين ثنائيه بينك وبين
روان مهدي وعملك كثير صور وقصص حب واشياء
زي كده بتتابع هذه الاشياء
اي والله اتابع انا من يعني والحلو الشاي
اللي جاي يحطونه من دفعه بيروت يحطونه
بيروت مع دفعه لندن بس والفنانه اوجه لها
تحيه فنانه جميله ورائعه رائعه
واستمتع انا بالمشاهد وياها وفي لو
يلاحظون في ابديت يعني شوفونا مع بعض من
دفعه بيروت لدفة لندن بس شخصيه مختلفه
تماما عن دفعه بيروت وان شاء الله دوم انا
وروان مهدي نمثل لنا للحين ما شبعنا
وعندنا اشياء وايد نبي نطلعها حق الناس
فالشكر يرجع حق الاستاذه مشاري حماده
الاختيارنا
الناس بعضهم يعني طبعا بيتابعوا المسلسل
وكل الكلام ده كله زي ما انت عارف في مديح
وفي جدل وفي النقد بعض الناس قالوا انه
انتم مطلعين او الشباب طالعين بصوره يمكن
خلينا نقول انه لا تمثل الشباب الكويتي
لانه مثلا في سكر في بنات فيما الى ذلك كل
هذه الا شياء وانه كانهم هم رايحين
للدراسه كيف بترد على هذه الانتقادات
كل واحد عنده انتقاد بالعكس الشيء السلبي
والشيء الايجابي كل واحد يقول رايه بشكل
عام
وناخذه بصدر رحب ونستمتع ونسمع الصح ونسمع
الغلط نسمع كل شيء بالنسبه احنا قاعد نسوي
حالات الطلاب
حياتهم الطبيعيه كثر ما هي الدراسه نشوف
الاكشن وبالنهايه احنا دراما لازم نسوي
شويه نفتح فيها الخطوط هذه مبين شلون
الخليجي او العربي او ايا شخص يسافر لندن
دراسه طبعا عنده اشياء بره فيها اكشن فيها
حب وفيها اشياء سياسيه فيها دينيه فيها
ايا كان انه حياه يعني واكيد تابعت كمان
الجدل اللي على الموضوع انه الاساءه
للمراه العراقيه
نعم شفنا والعراق تاج على راسنا واحنا
نغار على العراق وما
احد يغلط عليها
هذا في ناس مختصه يقدرون يردون على هالشيء
اكثر من ناصر واكثر من اي ممثل زملائي
اللي موجودين
وتابعوا يعني لا تحكموا من اول الحلقه او
ثاني حلقه
اخر حلقه راح تعرفون شنو الخطوط رايحه او
شنو الجنسيات رايحه لوين يعني كل صراحه
ايوه فعلا كل ما تكلمت مع احد من
المشاركين في هذا العمل كانوا بيقولوا انه
اصبروا على الحلقات استنوا شويه على
الحلقات وحتشوفوا يعني انه بزياده يعني
تفاصيل اكثر طيب الناس ليه ما بنشوفك في
اعمال سعوديه
والله وقت وانا قاعد اصور دفعه لندن جاني
خمسه اعمال سعوديه خمسه اي نعم
هذول ماني قادر ادخل اتمنى انه يعني الاجر
اللي اخذته عن دفعه يمكن يساوي الخمسه
اعمال اللي راحت
اعظم واحلى واجمل
واتشرف اني ادخل انا في الدراما السعوديه
كوني سعودي
وبدي حد كبير بيني وبين نفسي
هو الناس بتسال انت ليش اصلا مقيم في
الكويت وبتمثل اكثر في الدراما واللهجه
والكلام هذا كله والدتك كويتيه نعم
فانت نص كويتي نص سعودي طيب ناصر اي والله
معك حق صح
يعني خليني انقلك على اخر شيء انت بتشتغل
علينا عارف انك انت الان في مسرحيه جالس
بتعمل
بروفات اذا تحكيلنا عنها
اخراج اخوي بدر شيبي بطوله اخوي ابو عبد
الله بدر الشعيبي ناصر عباس فرح الصراف
فرح محمد عبد الرحمن اليحيوح من انتاج
شركه ترند برودكشن وتروح تكون على مسرح
صارت الدعيه صارت اليد شارع الحب مسوين
شيء مختلف تماما
عائلي الكبير والصغير راح ينبسط فيه
قصه تتكلم عن خمس ابطال خمس نجوم فيها
وكلهم في او سوري في 22 ممثل ما ذكرتهم ما
ابي ما ابي انسى احد
مختلف راح يكون بالعيد
ان شاء الله يعني بالتوفيق واصلا يعني
ناصر سنه عن سنه جالس بتسوي اشياء واعمال
صراحه جميله يعني السنه الماضيه من شارع
الهرم الى يعني كنت مره رهيب يعني الصراحه
وطبعا قبلها دفعه بيروت والكلام هذا كله
بس على العموم انا منحازه لك بشكل عام
يعني انا جدا دائما يعني اتمنى لك النجاح
والتوفيق وشكرا لك وان شاء الله تكون
المسرحيه مكسره الدنيا في العيد كمان
ومنتظرتك في دبي حسب بعدك اوكي طيب تسلم
لي شكرا يا ناصر كان معنا من الكويت ناصر
الدوسري